c'est vrai que pour ce métier là
faut pas avoir le vertige
là ça y est je suis arrivée à 40 mètres
de haut on est tout en haut et là je
vais vous montrer ma cabine c'est un peu
comme mon petit chez moi donc j'ai la
photo de ma fille j'ai monté en fait
c'est mon confort je m'appelle Bouchra
j'ai 27 ans et aujourd'hui on est sur de
travail voilà on est sur un chantier
parce que je suis grutier et derrière
moi voilà j'ai ma grue qui fait 40
mètres de haut ça fait un an que je suis
passionné de ça
de notre casque une fois qu'on est dans
notre cabine ça ça sert à rien en fait
j'ai deux manettes c'est une maladie ça
sert à orienté voilà
avancer mon chariot et ensuite on a
celui-ci c'est pour descendre le mouf et
le remonter c'est quoi le mot en fait
c'est là c'est ça c'est pour aller
chercher le matériel pour communiquer
entre nous c'est soit on a le tapis ok
avec ça on peut voilà ou sinon on a des
gestes par exemple ça c'est Mons tout
doucement descend doucement ou monte
vite voilà et moi je sais en fonction de
ça ben je gère en fait
on est en train de s'endormir on va
faire la sieste non non pas de sieste on
va finir ce chantier
c'est stressant quand même comme métier
parce que tu comprends pas des fois et
lui il s'énerve en bas toi aussi tu
t'énerves donc c'est prêt pour garder
son calme j'ai une pression parce qu'on
a toujours peur de de voilà de faire du
mal à quelqu'un ou faire une mauvaise
Manu c'est un métier qui est quand même
risqué pour nous et pour les gens qui
sont en bas qui travaillent avec nous il
fait des gestes on dit va à droite
donc on a des bons geeders ça marche
toujours bien je suis tombé sur un
chantier quand je suis arrivée bah tout
le monde tu es en PLS à une grue tiers
il y en a ben on est bien accueilli et
il y en a ils vont dire ah ça avance pas
le chantier ah c'est parce qu'il y a une
femme donc on a droit à des trucs comme
ça des propos comme ça j'ai pas de
vestiaire déjà j'ai pas de toilettes
pour femme c'est simple qui est un peu
difficile et voilà on est obligé de se
changer à la maison ou directement
devant mon véhicule voilà c'est un peu
chiant quoi de ne pas avoir des
toilettes pour les femmes aussi surtout
quand on est en période de règles mais
je m'adapte voilà je
sac poubelle on fait parler avec les
moyens et donc moi j'ai eu un sac
poubelle c'est avec ça que je fais mes
besoins c'est un milieu d'homme donc
c'est petit à petit qu'on voit des
femmes venir sur un chantier c'est ils
vont s'habituer je pense qu'ils nous
sommes habitué donc c'est une question
de temps
[Musique]
dans une chocolaterie avant je gagnais
pas bien ma vie et donc moi je voulais
sortir enfin je voulais en fait avoir un
confort et pour avoir ce confort là
fallait changer de métier pour regarder
plus et faut savoir que je suis une
femme célibataire avec un enfant à
charge et aujourd'hui la vie c'est c'est
dur quoi tout tout est cher toi augmenté
donc j'avais besoin de changer de métier
et un métier qui m'apporte un peu et où
un métier on peut évoluer aussi avant ma
vie voilà j'étais à 1300 euros j'étais
au SMIC et je m'en sortais pas là je
suis entre
2000 2003 en intérim ça fait du bien de
plus être à moins Crédit Mutuel
m'appelle plus en me disant madame vous
êtes à moins 500 euros je me tiens m'a
sauvé de ma dépression en fait j'ai été
victime de violences conjugale
du coup ça a duré longtemps cinq ans et
en fait j'étais en dépression j'étais
pas de moi je
on m'a beaucoup rabaissé en fait il m'a
rabaissé du coup ça m'a rendu encore
plus forte aujourd'hui pour moi c'est
une fierté de d'avoir ce diplôme là
aujourd'hui je suis grutier et c'est une
fierté pour moi je me sens moi je me
sens femme je me sens à ma place
[Musique]